there's a guy right now that could be
potentially looking for another job and
he was being interviewed on MSNBC by
this lady named Stephanie Rule and he
was asked the question I'm curious to
know if you would hire somebody like
this this is a phenomenal question here
there's not a Fortune 500 company in the
world looking to hire a CEO in his 80s
so why would an 82 year old Joe Biden be
the right person for the most important
job in the world because I've acquired a
hell of a lot of wisdom
I know more than the vast majority of
people are more experienced than
anybody's ever run for the office
I think I've proven myself to be
honorable as well as also effective
would you hire somebody like that to run
a I don't know like a
four or five trillion dollar your
company whatever the numbers 32 trillion
Auto Company give or take I could be off
on the GDP
you think that would be a good CEO for a
company that size
[Laughter]
could be a question that someone above
my pay grade
I I think that wait wait you're a voter
Tom let's see what he's got to say I I
think that the number one criteria to
run an organization you know is
humility
combined with a bit of wisdom
from life experience but combined with
an extraordinary amount of of energy you
know you you have to eat sleep and breed
the thing
and I think that organizations that have
um that have people with too much
confidence they tend to go off the rails
and so it's good to know what you don't
know
got it so so to understand the what you
meant we have to speak sign language so
he left it to you guys you decide what
our Frontier meant by that whether he
but just just for your own company if
you were getting to a point where you
would be replacing yourself as a CEO
would you look at somebody and value a
person with you know who's 82 years old
wanting to be the CEO microstrategy or
would you look for somebody younger or
would it even matter to you age-wise
well I mean I did have the opportunity
to replace myself last year and I'm the
executive chairman and we're we
appointed a new CEO and the CEO is Fong
Lee and and he's um
he's in his 40s okay early 40s so you
weren't like you weren't going on like
senior ceos.com and looking for
recruiters to to find like I mean that's
not even seniors right because baby
boomer is what 1946 to 64. so you
weren't interested in experience
and I'm I'm not going to say the perfect
age to be CEO because there are a lot of
examples I mean I I myself appointed
myself CEO at age 24 but then again I
was only responsible for myself and I
couldn't mess much up because I
inherited you know and it took me many
many years to get to the point where I
could break something
well I think that the bigger the
organization the more careful one needs
to be this is a pretty big organization
we're talking about and this guy's
applying for that job so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign